chaos on the streets of ramallah
a group of pro-government supporters
marched down to where around 100
protesters had gathered
peacefully chanting slogans against the
palestinian authority
protesters were beaten and members of
the media were aggressively targeted
and what many say has been a concerted
campaign against the press
camera cards were forcibly removed and
taken a colleague had his camera smashed
we were surrounded by thugs who forced
us to bring down the satellite antenna
on our broadcasting truck
they are security members you know but
with the civil clause
they related to different
security military intelligence
and which called the the president
guards
also this is part of that most of them
you know
they are not civilians they are security
members
it's the fourth day of protests
following the death of palestinian
authority critic
nizar banat according to his family he
was beaten in the middle of the night
and detained by members of the
palestinian security forces last
thursday
anger at the government here is rising
84
of the palestinian people say in polls
that the palestinian authority is
corrupt
so that's the first issue the second
issue is that the pa has become an
authoritarian regime
they are arresting activists they are
beating people in the streets
and last but not least the palestinian
people want to
struggle for freedom want to struggle
for justice the settlements are
expanding
and we see the pa and and the pa's role
has been
assisting the occupation preventing the
palestinian struggle
scenes like this rarely seen here a
large number of security forces were
stationed not far from this
and did nothing we reached out to
various members of the government no one
has so far
given us a response the level of
intimidation over the media over the
last couple of days has been
immense female journalists have been
beaten with sticks we were severely
intimidated not a film
to bring down our live capabilities and
they continue to watch us to the point
where we couldn't even take out our
mobile phones and all this prompted by a
protest of only around a hundred
or so people stephanie decker al jazeera
ramallah
in the occupied west bank